BAD.
AND THE COUNTRY WOULD HE HEARD
AS A RESULT OF IT.
AS WE PREDICTED, 45 REPUBLICAN
SENATORS INCLUDING MITCH
MCCONNELL, YES THEY DID IN FAVOR
OF A MOTION DECLARING THAT THE
PROCEEDINGS AGAINST DONALD TRUMP
AND OTHERS ARE UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THIS LATEST DEMOCRATIC SHOW IS
NOW OFFICIALLY DEAD IN THE
WATER, IT IS OVER, THE SENATE
TRIAL WILL BE CONDUCTED AT PLAN,
BUT THE DEMOCRATS DO NOT HAVE
ANYWHERE CLOSE TO WHAT WOULD BE
THAT TWO THIRDS SUPER MAJORITY
THAT WOULD BE NEEDED TO CONVICT.
BARRING ANY COMPLETELY UNLIKELY
LAST-MINUTE REVERSALS FROM
PEOPLE THAT ARE WEAK AND WOULD
GO AGAINST THEIR OWN
CONSTITUTIONAL BELIEFS, DONALD
TRUMP WILL BE ACQUITTED AND WHAT
WE WILL WITNESS THE YET ANOTHER
COLOSSAL WASTE OF TIME WITH A
PREDETERMINED OUTCOME AND A SHOW
TRIAL PREDICATED UPON A RATIONAL
PSYCHOTIC RAGE OF THE RADICAL
LEFT AND THE DEMOCRATS IN
COMPLETE FEAR AND PANIC YOU
STAND UP TO THEIR BASE.
INCLUDING THE LUNATIC FRINGE
THAT CONTROLS THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ESTABLISHMENT
AND THE U.S. SENATE CANNOT
VALIDATE THIS SNAP IMPEACHMENT.
YOU KNOW, WITH ZERO EVIDENCE,
ZERO INVESTIGATION, ZERO
DEFENSE, KEEP IN MIND THAT WE
NOW HAVE REPORTS ALL OVER THE
PLACE OF EVEN "THE WASHINGTON
POST", REAL COURT DOCUMENTS
SHOWING THAT INVESTIGATORS
BELIEVE A LOT OF PLANNING WAS
MADE IN ADVANCE OF WHAT HAPPENED
ON JANUARY 6.
IN OTHER WORDS THE PRESIDENT DID
NOT CITE AN INSURRECTION AND
THEY IGNORE THE PRESIDENT’S OWN
WORDS, THEY WILL BE MARCHING TO
THE CAPITAL SO THAT THE VOICES
WILL BE HEARD.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE TRIAL WILL
NOW ACCOMPLISH NOTHING, IT IS
POLITICAL THEATER FRANKLY AT ITS
WORST, WASHINGTON AT ITS WORST,
IT IS A MASSIVE GOVERNMENT WASTE
OF TIME AND RESOURCES AND BY THE
WAY, MONEY IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC.
WE HAVE A DIVISIVE SELF-SERVING
PARADE, ONE FOR THAT OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
75 MILLION AMERICANS WHO VOTED
FOR HIM, AS WELL IS ANOTHER WAY
FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO RAISE
MONEY, THOSE TO EASE THE RADICAL
SOCIALIST PHASE.
THEY SAID THAT THEY HAVE NOT
ENOUGH VOTES YET THEY BELIEVE
THAT THE SHOW TRIAL IMPEACHMENT
MUST GO ON, BUT CHIEF JUSTICE IS
REFUSING TO PARTICIPATE.
IT IS A CLEARLY BUNCH OF
UNCONSTITUTIONAL PROCEEDINGS AND
THAT INCLUDES ROBERT’S NOT
EXACTLY BEING A DONALD TRUMP FAN
AS I CAN BE, NOW A DEMOCRATIC
EDITOR, HE IS GOING TO FILL THE
VOID LEFT BY THE CHIEF JUSTICE,
PATRICK LEAHY OF ABOUT TO BE AN
IMPARTIAL AND FAIR JUDGE AND
CALLING FOR IT TO BE CONVICTED
IN THE CASE.
IT’S UNCONSTITUTIONAL FOR THE
SENATE TO TRY A PRIVATE CITIZEN
AND REMOVE HIM FROM AN OFFICE
THAT THEY NO LONGER HOLD, THE
SENATE HAS NO JURISDICTION AND
REMINDING THAT THEY ARE NOTHING
BUT A PARTISAN DEMOCRAT AND BY
THE WAY THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TEMPTED TO CONVICT A FORMER
PRESIDENT ON AN INCITEMENT
CHARGE THAT THEY THEMSELVES, IF
THEY EVER EXAMINE THEIR OWN
WORDS, ARE GUILTY OF.
EARLIER TODAY SENATOR RAND PAUL
OF KENTUCKY CALLED UPON THIS
RAMPANT HYPOCRISY THAT WE HAVE
BEEN CALLING OUT REGULARLY ON
THIS PROGRAM.
>> IF WE WERE ABOUT TO TALK
ABOUT THIS, WHERE IS THE CHIEF
JUSTICE.
WHERE IS THE CONSTITUTIONAL
POWER TO IMPEACH HIM.
PRIVATE CITIZENS DO NOT GET
IMPEACHED.
IMPEACHMENT IS FOR REMOVAL FROM
OFFICE, HYPER PARTISAN DEMOCRATS
ARE ABOUT TO DRAG OUR GREAT
COUNTRY DOWN INTO THE GUTTER OF
RANCOR AND VITRIOL AND IT’S
ALMOST AS IF THEY HAVE NO
ABILITY TO EXIST IN OPPOSITION
TO DONALD TRUMP.
THEY MIGHT HAVE TO LEGISLATE
WITHOUT HIM AS THEIR BUSY MAN